Moving forward.
It is good that we can
access elements in a, but
another important operation is assigning
values to specific location in a.
This will give us access to the element
at the position 0, 0 in the a.
Using the assignment operator,
we can assign a value one to it.
Let's see the output.
Here you go.
This is the original array where we
replaced the element at 00 with 1, but
that's not all,
with the minor change you can assign
a value to the entire row or column.
Let's do it.
This will give us access
to the 0 true and
we assign the entire row a value of 2.
Let's run this.
Using similar operation and
column slicing, we can also assign
an entire column a single values.
Now what if we need each column or
row to have different value and
not the same as we did over here?
Let's see how we can achieve this.
Yes, this is a list of values.
You can assign a list of
values to a row or a column.
Here we assign this list of values
to column number three, but
make sure you keep
an eye on the dimension.
That is, for this example,
if you have five rows in an area
the list should have five elements.
As you can see, all the list values
have been assigned to the third column.
So now it's your turn.
Go ahead and try more row and
column slicing.